I hope you enjoyed that let's have a
look at this that you've already made
that heading the date is the 20th okay
now just let me make a little noise I
keep calling this like it very nice is
it
I can't call this optimization even
though frequently we did in the context
of school you hear it key record maximum
maximum maximum problems right
optimization it's what it's called in
the real world like you're trying to
optimize for something now the question
is what are we optimizing for you can
optimize for a variety of things okay
and in fact that's what the great things
about having done this I haven't given
you a question what question would you
ask it like the visual rhetorically
speaking and what could you ask you this
now I will give you the classical one
okay um you can have a pick it up what
lot of options there are the classical
problem is well which of these open
prisms has the biggest volume that is
the classical question to ask so let's
write that down which I've been prism
has the maximum volume I would prefer to
state this excite Molly I would pursue
my mistake this in a simple language
which one's the biggest but
unfortunately biggest hazard so I need
to stay volume is what a long time yeah
I could ask which one is the largest
surface area that is another equally
valid question to ask and you will get
ready answer for it as well which is
really three but everything we've
learned all the theory and all the
methods and skills right we can take all
of them to tackle this very very simple
and I might add very practical question
let's have a go at this right now in
order to get this right which every
prism is the maximum volume okay clearly
I need an expression for the volume
right and that expression can change
look they all have different volumes
right um some of them may have the same
value but like as I go along
suddenly this volume here is gonna be
different to the ones before it and
different to the one before and so on so
you can see like probably you could
guess but this one is so shallow and
thank you
right that it's not likely to be able to
hold as much as one of the ones further
along but as you go up to this end you
like oh that's clearly very small in
fact most of you will be able to intuit
and sort of guessed well it looks like
this one is objectively smaller than
this one right remembering that if you
think about them on different axes they
have the same height they're both one
centimeter tall do you see that right
like this one is one centimeter this way
and this one is one centimeter this way
right and that that's clearly smaller
and I okay why at least I know there's
something but in the middle I've got the
most which one has the biggest body so
to begin a to begin what we're trying to
do is we're trying to solve for and I'm
going to write this down to show you
what's going on in my head you don't
have to write all of this down but the
first time we're tackling this and it is
enormously instructive to scatter all
the thought process okay so we're try to
solve for maximum I'm going to call the
volume V often the question will tell
you let let the variable that you're
interested in which is going to change
my to be equal to so for maximum V and
as I go along from left to right I'm
changing a value and I'm really changing
one value right let me just turn me in
on that per second it looks like I'm
changing more than one value right
because each of these well how do you
define what numbers do you need to
define the volume of a rectangular prism
how many numbers do you need you need
three you need legs
what weird mmm and height right length
width and height sounds like three
numbers right but do you remember as I
asked you okay I'd like you to draw this
one or this one or this one of this on
this one you actually only really had
one number right all you needed was one
number and you could produce that
reitman what was the number I gave you
corresponding to these prisons I give
you the height right so remember for
example I gave mark one this is an easy
table right I gave mark one so when you
cut out that from the corners that's
what ends up folding up which gives you
a height right and then like I don't
know
five are in here which again fold up and
give you that height that's exactly
right
it does get strong for however you don't
need to know like you know I don't have
to tell you okay I want this number and
then I want a number for the area this
the area of the base is a function of
the number I gave you at the beginning
right in fact this is a critical skill
to identify even though we're trying to
stop the maximum volume and it looks
like there are multiple numbers involved
you have to get everything out of one
number as it happens you can't actually
differentiate when you have more
variables but that's something you learn
at university corner partial
differential equations but you don't
need to worry about okay we want one
variable this is called single variable
calculus you can only differentiate for
instance dy with respect to u DX we
don't know how to differentiate ya when
you've got multiple variables flying
around so you need one so I'm gonna say
solve for maximum V fine and this is a
bit of a technical way of saying it but
by very now what did you say that number
was again like geometrically it was the
height right so I'm gonna call it h you
can call it if you like I mean you can
call it X if you like or R or T but
you're generally going to get like as
these questions increasing complexity
you're gonna get more and more variables
flying around so it is in your interest
to try and pick a letter a friend and
hold that time okay
I don't need to double think about what
this is I can just say Oh H is almost
always time okay so if I were to solve
for maximum V by varying H I'm looking
for a turning point I'm looking for a
maximum turning point right so therefore
I need V as a function of page again I'm
just gonna write this down as my thought
process right and therefore I need V as
a function of H and that's the way that
I would say that okay I need to know to
say V equals blah blah blah blah and
it's all got of H's in them if I have
other stuff in there I'm in trouble
okay so what is the volume of this shape
I can hear we need to return back to our
original
or piece of paper okay a piece of
cardboard right yeah I'm actually going
to superfly this a little bit just to
make the numbers easier I could use the
real numbers it will just turn out a
little bit Messier but just for the sake
of illustration I'm gonna make the
numbers simpler from what I understand a
April piece of paper is 21 centimeters
wide and 29 centimeters tall a 2129 both
kind of gross numbers okay so even
though all the presses I'm going to show
you they will still work with 21 to 29
shall split-second of simplicity I'm
gonna call it 20 and 30 okay is that all
right so I'm gonna call this distance
across here 20 and I'm gonna call this
distance okay it's close enough for my
intents and purposes and if you like
after we go through this process you can
rehearse it for 21 and 29 the tools will
be the same and the process will be much
the same the numbers were just being
Messier
alright now when I took my piece of um
cardboard I cut squares out I cut
squares out so for example we might all
do something like this obviously the
actual number I gave you will give you a
different sized square but the whole
point is that I can bury this right so
this is just one particular
visualization one example okay
now that number you supply became the
side length of that square which then
turned into the height of the prism okay
so therefore I have h's all over the
place here right now think and if you
have another color here this will help
right we already know one of the
dimensions will be H okay as you fold it
up but what will the other two
dimensions be if you are actually
looking at a face on it's going to be
the base solve um it's gonna be the area
of the base right now where is the base
on this diagram okay remember you fold
them up and you fold it up do you
remember that right like this by the way
is the reason I got you to do it so you
could see what was going on so therefore
my base is actually here even we call it
base
that is the rectangular base I actually
end up with now if you know that then
it's not that difficult to work out the
dimensions of the base for instance
let's look at the width of the base the
width of the base is going to be 20 but
you've subtracted this edge and this
edge does that make sense
so therefore the width as I'm looking at
it this way is 20 take away 2h that's
what you have to have right and by um by
analogy the height of my face looking at
it at this orientation is gonna be 30
minus 2h okay so now coming back to
prison mode and I'm not going to worry
about it just being a base right a
rectangle I have a lake I have the width
I have the height I can write down
volume as a function of either Hut right
not volume is three different things but
Volume II all in terms of this one
variable let's write that down